first came the age of the great ones
they were mysterious powerful beings
each one of them completely unique from
the last then came the age of the
Tamarians the great ones once lived
alongside the Tamarians
but eventually ascended to a higher
realm leaving the Tamarians behind
finally came the age of man a group of
whom discovered the tombs of the great
ones and the Tamarians who now guarded
them these were the bergen worth
scholars a group devoted to seeking the
truth
they burrowed deep into this world that
they didn't understand uncovering relics
rituals and a race that had not been
disturbed for a very long time most
importantly though they stumbled upon a
substance called the old blood this
blood was incredibly powerful as a
transfusion with it could cure any
illness this blood split the ranks of
the Bergen worth scholars for they could
not agree on how it was to be used the
head of the scholars a man named Willem
believed that humanity would be undone
by the blood our eyes have yet to open
he said so we should fear it other
scholars disagreed probably thinking him
cowardly one man Lawrence was much more
headstrong than his mentor he disagreed
with Willem abandoned him and went on to
found the healing Church a society built
upon the use of the old blood but there
was a third man who betrayed the Bergen
Wirth scholars he stole what the
scholars considered forbidden blood and
took it far away to the nobles of
cainhurst castle
a man named Alfred tells us this once a
scholar betrayed his fellow is at Bergen
worth and brought forbidden blood back
with him to cainhurst castle it was
there that the first of the inhuman
vilebloods was born
the file Bloods are fiendish creatures
who threatened the purity of the
church's blood healing the ruler of the
vilebloods is still alive today and so
to honor my Master's wishes I search for
the path to cainhurst castle the people
of cainhurst were proud and Noble with a
society made up of three tiers at the
bottom were the servants and the knights
above them were the nobles indulgent and
arrogant and above them all was one the
queen this queen received the forbidden
blood that was stolen from Bergen worth
and became what Alfred calls a vile
blood from here cainhurst begins to
parallel yharnam in many ways for
example beasts appear which are dealt
with by the Knights of cainhurst the
Queen gives employee to hunters who hunt
not beasts but other hunters these are
her blood hunters who seek blood dregs
to feed their beloved queen so that she
may one day bear a child of blood the
vilebloods become the sworn enemies of
the church for as far as we know Yanam
and cainhurst are the only two places
with two different strains of the old
blood it was only natural that they
would become rivals so the church forms
a group called
the executioner's headed by master
ligarius the executioner's were zealots
and existed for the sole purpose of
destroying impurity wherever it was
found through multiple generations they
searched for the vilebloods of cainhurst
castle eventually they found them and
departed in force to exact their
vengeance in his time master logarius
led his executioner's into cainhurst
castle to cleanse it of the vilebloods
but all did not go well and master
ligarius became a blessed anchor
guarding us from evil
tragic tragic times that master logarius
should be abandoned in the accursed
domain of the vilebloods
i must free him so that he may be
properly honored in martyrdom
problem is Alfred does not know how to
get to K Nast yet in yosef cos clinic in
the clinic where we first awoke there's
a curious invitation in the back room an
old blood-stained summons inviting an
honored guest to the forsaken castle
cainhurst rather bafflingly it is
addressed to you
perhaps it's why we even came to Yanam
in the first place
do not hesitate the stagecoach leaves
from him wink across him while we're in
cainhurst
we can attempt to clarify where good and
evil lie ligarius leader of the
executioner's once said acts of goodness
are not always wise and acts of evil are
not always foolish but regardless we
shall always strive to be good but who
is ligarius to label good and evil the
world is not black and white
yet his judgement led to the slaughter
of the people of cainhurst so did these
people deserve to be slaughtered we
arrived and the first thing we notice is
that the beasts here are different
very few are wolf-like like those in
yharnam and in fact they appear to have
evolved according to their environment
blood liquors roam bloating themselves
on the corpses over the Fallen that lie
beneath the snow and gargoyles imitate
the architecture patiently waiting for
their prey in the halls of cainhurst
roamed the ghosts of Nobles undying and
ethereal upon the tallest tower of
cainhurst we find ligarius alone
ligarius and his executioner's
slaughtered every vileblood noble until
one remained the queen to his despair
ligarius discovered that the queen was
immortal she could be rendered crushed
and broken but there was always the
threat that her flesh would reform so he
took the only option available to him he
donned at the old king's crown a
powerful heirloom of cainhurst it
allowed him to hide cainhurst castle and
the queen away from the world so that no
one would ever stumble upon the last
vial
we murder the withered ligarius and we
are granted audience with Queen Annalise
visitor I claim no subject but here
lieth are thrown near lavoris or get be
gone
Neal visitor hunter I am Annalise queen
of castle cainhurst ruler of the
vilebloods pan a sworn enemy of the
church yet our people are murdered and
we are prisoner to this wretched mask
what is it that in search on it appears
that if you were invited to gain Hearst
you will always be able to find it AHA
is that the sigil of cainhurst I've
heard tell of cainhurst nobles and their
amusingly pompous invitations wonderful
I thank you profusely I feel my master's
hand at work praise the good blood and
let us cleanse these tarnished streets
the order of the executioner's believe
in martyrdom that is they believe in
suffering or dying for a holy cause
Marta ligarius suffers here on his
Frozen Throne to keep the world safe
from a perceived evil but it cannot be
considered absolute martyrdom for the
Queen remains alive as does ligarius
Alfred deeply desires to kill this woman
and perhaps even his master as well
these deaths would allow his idol to
pass into legend as a true martyr who
died for the greater good
Master look I've done it I've done it
smashed pounded and ground in this
rotten siren into fleshy think about
there you give a monstrosity for goods
your immortality now try stirring up
trouble in this sorry state
Oh mangled and twisted with every inside
on the outside for all the world to see
[Laughter]
look at this
thanks to you I'm
well indeed wonderful now master can be
canonized as a true martyr
ironically Alfred coming here and
killing the Queen would have run counter
to ligarius as wishes the Queen is
undying so without a guardian there is
always the risk that she could rise
again
that is why ligarius stood guard here
for all these years yet of course acts
of goodness are not always wise so
Alfred kills himself so that he can
become a martyr
along with his beloved master and as
Alfred lies dead we take the flesh of
the Queen and resurrect her in a world
now devoid of executioner's so that the
vilebloods may rise again well well an
odd hunter thou art indeed we've tired
of these piteous Knights share in our
plight and take earth against the church
drink deal
[Music]
now there are two a vileblood we do the
very last on this earth we await thy
return
for the honor of caste
[Music]
you